when's the last time you sat down and
thought is this life that I have the
life that I want
and if it isn't what am I doing each day
to work towards the life I do want now
from my experience of the doctor and
also probably from your experience
watching or listening to this we
probably know that we don't really treat
mental health in the same way as we
treat physical health and so with that
in mind today's episode is an interview
between me and Dr Alex George now Dr
Alex is a TV Doctor best-selling author
and youth mental health ambassador to
the government now as you might be aware
if you're in the UK Dr Alex was first
featured on love Island about five years
ago and love Island this reality TV show
kind of catapulted him to fame his first
book is called live well every day that
was released in 2021 and became a Sunday
Times bestseller and he has recently
released this second book of a mind
manual mental Fitness tools for everyone
it's an idea I talk about in the mind
manual it's called the traffic light
Theory we go around we would say red
Amber or green how you're feeling today
now if I said that I was Amber every day
maybe every day the similar stress or
pressure was I was facing maybe I just
can't get quite on top of my sleep it
allows you and as that person to learn
about why they might feel a certain way
also allows the people around you to
learn what's normal for them we talk a
lot about mental health about the stigma
around mental health and we explore some
of Alex's own personal experiences and
personal history with struggling with
mental health issues including anxiety
and including the fact that his brother
died from suicide a couple of years ago
remember sitting there literally like
sobbing away reading it being like it's
going to get better it's going to get
better and thank God it did it did get
better and after eight to ten weeks
it was like a cloud lifted okay Dr Alex
thank you very much for coming on the
Pod thank you very much for having me
you talk a lot about the idea of uh
mental Fitness uh what what does mental
fitness mean
um I mean I chose uh the word mental
Fitness to sit along uh the Mind manual
as the title of my book or the subtitle
and the reason I chose that is I think a
lot of the time we view mental health as
this inherently bad thing in fact if you
say physical health to someone they'll
conjure ideas of Joe Wicks running in
the park fitness they might even say
things like cardiovascular weights yeah
they might say Illness but I bet you'd
be a lot of positive connotations if you
say mental health is always or almost
always depression anxiety sadness or you
know we need you know does that person
have mental health or this person in
headline papers admits to having mental
health it's like you have a heartbeat
you have both physical health and mental
health you know this and so I I feel
very passionately we need to change the
conversation around it so that when we
think of mental health we don't
automatically jump to that negative
subsection in a way I guess it's that
spectrum is now one end got perfect
mental health which hardly anyone has
and this end you have severe mental
illness which a percentage of people
have most people sit somewhere along
here and the good news is that you can
build upon that you know in the same way
you know I wouldn't go right I've
completed the gym I've been the gym for
the last year never need to go to the
gym never need to work on my physical
fitness again what happens if I stop
going to the gym I get weaker my
cardiovascular drops off my life
expectancy would change are more
vulnerable to the disease I'd be less
productive
it's not good and mental Fitness is the
same if you work on it and you build and
you keep watering that plant it grows to
be a strong you know tree or shrub
whatever you'd like it to be but it'll
be strong and that's why I believe in
mental Fitness okay beautiful
um so this conversation we're going to
talk about a bunch of these mental
Fitness tools um before we go there one
thing that you talk about a bit is about
trying to Define what normal looks like
for you what do you what do you mean by
that and how does one go about defining
normal for them I think a lot of the
time
um in society we set a lot of standards
of expectations or ideals of what
someone should be like in reality we're
all very different we have different
genetic makeups our nurture is very
different our environments are different
um our neuro development might be
different and so learning what the
normal is for you is the bit that
matters because you know there's a huge
variation between people and I think a
lot of the time and happiness can stem
from the fact that you're constantly
chasing something which for you isn't
necessarily achievable or for you might
not be your ideal of Peace So an example
an easy example would be like if you're
an introvert versus you're an extrovert
you're ideal of how you live your life
and what a good day feels like to you
it's gonna be very different like my
idea of a good day is spending a little
bit of quality time with people I care
about a lot of time in nature in a
decent amount of time alone that could
be health or some extroverts yeah and so
you need to learn what your normal
environment of what you want your life
to be but also what am I like you know
what do I feel like and how has that
changed and people often ask me how do I
know if you know someone's struggling
how do I know if my son or daughter is
in a bad place I say well what's normal
for them if it's changed and they've
gone from this kind of person to someone
that they weren't a few weeks and months
ago then that tells you that something
has happened and so learning a normal
about yourself very important but also
understanding you know looking around
you look and listen hear feel gut
instinct is a a powerful
um idea and it works or we know from you
know seeing patients in the hospital I
know you're going to talk about the
collab of fancy tests and the CRPS and
inflammatory markers all the stuff but a
lot of the time the psychometer as we
call it comes from gut instinct doesn't
it yeah does this feel right or not yeah
yeah it like it reminds me of when when
doing a Pediatrics placement a lot of
the question is like how is the kid
relative to what's normal for them and
the parents would be like oh come on
there must be something more objective
it's like no honestly if it's normal for
them it's probably fine if it's not
normal for them it's probably not fine
it's an idea I talk about in the mind
manual and I I talk about a lot actually
when I visit schools and universities
and I've had great feedback from this
and it's a great way to work out what
normal is for people you know around you
and also get you to reflect on your own
normal and it's called the traffic light
Theory so say we're sat here now we've
got croissants here we could be having a
lovely lunch together we could have our
children around the table and we'd go
around we'd say red Amber or green how
you're feeling today red being bad you
get the idea now if I said that I was
Amber every day and I wasn't quite
feeling great but I wasn't terrible and
I was able just to articulate a few
reasons why like maybe every day the
similar stress or pressure was I was
facing maybe I just can't get quite on
top of my sleep it allows you and as
that person to learn about why they
might feel a certain way also allows the
people around you to learn what's normal
for them but then all of a sudden if
this person that was maybe green a lot
of the time suddenly becomes red maybe
three or four days in a row it makes you
go hang on what's happened Something's
Happened Here that's changed and the
great thing is about having going around
in a circle around the table and using
this is that you all learn from each
other as to what things actually make up
good mental health versus what might
drag your mental health down and so I
think it's a really it's a really
powerful tool to use to learn about your
own normal and other people's normals
and that's why you know a lot of this
stuff I mean how long does it take to
sit around a dinner table and do that
traffic like Theory a few moments yeah
it was actually used um in the pandemic
by a lot of intensive care nurses um I
believe one of the ones I heard was UCL
and they were using at the start of end
of certain end of the Handover shifts to
basically identify nurses that were
struggling that were burnt out so the
senior management senior matrons could
focus their support on those that are
saying I'm red I've been working five
days in a row I'm knackered and and so
on and it allows that early
identification I think that's one of the
biggest things when we go back to like
why is mental health viewed badly why do
we have such high suicide rates
particularly amongst men it's because I
think in certain subsection Society
we're not that great at like recognizing
our own struggles and acting upon them
all the struggles of other others and
when you talk about men's mental health
I mean why are men up to 10 times more
like to take their own life than a woman
well you know is that because of their
genetics is it the testosterone level
men and women are actually incredibly
similar there are slight variations in
our makeup I mean when you look at the
grand scheme of extreme event we're
actually incredibly similar there are
slight differences most of the theory
around why it's so much higher in men
comes from the way that we brought men
up to be if you've grown up with man up
grow some balls don't be a girl and all
these kind of harmful things is it a
surprise that when we've been teaching
men to be tough and speaking and sharing
is emasculating when they're at the
point of their weakness how are they
going to do what most unnatural to them
and for them so it's it's so important
that we do these things and we embed
these kind of techniques into family and
into the into family dynamic because it
teaches us new law it teaches our own
normal it means that we can talk about
things when things are abnormal it's
like in the hospital isn't that you know
um the most dangerous scenarios when
you've got a team that isn't
communicating to each other when someone
is aware of something and there's a
patient they're worried about but
they're afraid to talk out and it's very
similar in mental health in a way to
keep quiet keep quiet keep quiet and
eventually this problem becomes so big
it spills over you've got a cardiac
arrest on the ward and everyone goes
yeah but the sodium's been this high for
three days why didn't you say anything
because you were stressed because the
feedback I mean I've done so many uh
talks and I've done I've visited schools
from Scotland all the way up to the
North Coast of Scotland uh down to the
South Coast next country island Wales
ever at universities as well and it's
been one of the most popular things I've
suggested for families workplaces small
teams it's it's great it works so well
red Emma green uh we tried that once in
a team meeting and it was really helpful
and we just completely forgot about it
since then so I'm gonna revive if that
goes back to this point and people go oh
yeah we've been talking about mental
health it requires discipline one of the
biggest cons in the mental health space
and the well-being industry is that it's
easy that is an absolute con it's hard
work there's a very good uh saying that
you know nothing worthwhile in life
comes easily and I believe that to be
absolutely true in the same way you've
got to go to the gym if you want to get
really strong you've got to go and do
squats you lift heavy weights you're
breathless if you like me you're
sweating like a pig and you're walking
out nearly collapsing after a hard
workout it's the same with your mental
Fitness as well you've got to dedicate
time and energy you know you talk so
much about productivity but discipline's
a huge part of productivity isn't it
that kind of motivation versus
discipline you know motivation lasts a
few weeks I mean we can see that by how
many people retain going to the gym from
the start first of January to the end of
January it's like 90 of people no longer
in the gym that's because they relied on
motivation motivation must quickly be
replaced by discipline so emote debate
as a team to start this traffic light
system but the discipline needs to take
over because discipline mitigates for
all of that does Mr discipline doesn't
care how you feel doesn't how tired you
are it just knows that it needs to
happen and yeah I think I think that's
the the con in the industry because and
also the problem of selling this story
that oh it should be fluffy and easy all
the time the problem is is that when it
isn't people think they're doing it
wrong that they should give up and it's
not working you know sometimes it's the
hard work like therapy is a good example
going to therapy is hard I have therapy
every Wednesday it's really hard talking
about difficult things talking about
past traumas talking about stuff that I
maybe don't want to talk about but I can
only get better by going through the
hard stuff how long have you been doing
therapy I've been having therapy on and
off for I think it's been about three or
four years now and I've got to the point
where I have therapy every week and it's
I know it's a privilege I know that it's
therapy is expensive but it's the best
70 80 pounds that I spend in my in my
week by far in fact I feel it's
absolutely essential for me you know
I've been through a lot of different
things in my life we all have and
there's many things I don't think I
could deal with without the support of
my therapist and I think that I'm a
better friend family member I'm more
productive and certainly generally more
at peace in my life because I have
therapy every week it makes a huge
difference to me have you had therapy I
had my very first session uh about an
hour ago before we started recording
this good timing for this great timing
yeah it was so good
um well no I I think I I dabbled with a
couple of sessions in in the past and
had like an online one and but this was
and how did you find it that's really
good
um in the past I've sort of tried to two
different therapists and I sort of felt
like we didn't really have anything to
talk about and they didn't really get me
but this new guy
um who I've started working with James I
feel like he really gets it and the
thing I'm trying to work on or you know
focus on is feeling my emotions in a
sort of more conscious way
because I think I have drunk the
Kool-Aid of like I'm a chill guy stoes
is a man up don't be a girl don't be gay
all all of the stuff that you get are
sort of growing up uh in in a boys
Secondary School in the UK and I'm sure
in other places around the world as well
that uh encourage uh encourage us to
repress and suppress our emotions did
you find it it's interesting because um
even in those and you know I mean I've
seen your your work and your content for
a long time even as someone that is
quite reflective as you are you're quite
open I think as a person you're quite
transparent about things even as that
person who actually on the scale of prep
stoicism or being worried about being
emasculating you're on the spectrum of
being someone quite open I'm a pretty
open gun you're still affected by it
isn't that it's not true so for so for
those that perhaps are less like that
yeah it's even it's even harder and it
takes a long time to unlearn this stuff
I mean you know something like 80 to 90
of our neurodevelopments done by the age
of five years old and so the things that
we hear in our early years are so so
important and they can be often quite
hard this can be often quite hard to
unlearn the good news is that you you
can unlearn those things and people go
why does that matter well understanding
about the way you are and your natural
reactions to situations means you're
better adapted to deal with things
better and also you're less likely to
have conflict I mean you know the one of
the biggest challenges we often face in
our lives is difficulties in
relationships maybe finding the right
person being happy in our relationship
knowing whether we're the right person
these kind of things you know one of the
top searched things on YouTube is around
relationship stuff and break up and
heartbreak advice is up there and one of
the best things you can do is to learn
about yourself I mean the whole book
attached which is you know a massive
book of fantastic I'd I'd advise anyone
to to read it's a it's an Evidence
research-based book that I think is
um I think it is shared or was written
in a way that's very accessible you know
it talks about this idea that you can be
securely attached securely attached
which if they say about 50 of the
population I think that's probably way
off that but you get the kind of idea
these are people that will be
comfortable in scenarios they won't lean
towards avoidance they won't lean
towards anxiety they're set more in the
middle then you have your anxious you
have your avoidance and your anxiously
avoidance and I think even just
understanding a little bit about that
stuff really helps and and so if you
have therapy you know I think it can
make a difference to to anyone's life
regardless if you have something to talk
about I think I one of the most common
things I get asked is how how do I know
if I'm bad enough for therapy well the
first thing is if you're asking me am I
bad enough for therapy your answer is
not yes you're bad enough but it means
you need therapy I mean to but but
actually the irony of the whole point is
that is that you don't need to need it
to need it I think everyone can benefit
again it's like going to the gym and
saying I've got the gym mastered I know
how to use everything in here there's no
way I can improve my training techniques
if so why why do we bother having
training athlete trainers and stuff like
that and you know pts for Olympians and
why are they continuously mastering the
art of their their technique we can all
learn and I think if you can add
10 of you know we use we'll talk about
happiness maybe later but we'll use the
the currency of Happiness if you can
feel 10 happiness happier wouldn't you
think that's worth that in your day I
mean most of us would like to feel a
little bit less suffering and a little
bit happier so if anyone's listening to
this and going oh I don't know if
therapy is for me
I really think everyone could benefit
from it and the point you made you have
to connect with a therapist it is a
human interaction it requires two people
to feel comfortable to share and
reciprocate and understand so if you are
with a therapist who you feel that
you're not you don't feel that you can
share or you don't think they get get
you just find another therapist I could
be with one therapist I really connect
with and you could be with that same
therapist you can have them sorry I
connect with them and you don't that's
fine they won't get offended by it
therapists are very used to it they know
they know how it is so find someone that
works for you
well so I'm I'm fully with you on this I
think therapy is almost like and I think
I've drunk the uh Alanda baton Kool-Aid
on this uh therapy therapy is like you
know having a personal trainer in that
just because like it's it's a thing that
just helps you improve your health
rather than a thing that you should get
once you've had an injury but then I'm
you know I mentioned to my mom at one
point that yeah I was thinking of
starting therapy and my mum's a
consultant psychiatrist and she's like
quite
anti-normal people having therapy if
there is nothing to like work on and she
views it as a like medical intervention
and you wouldn't just to really nearly
give a medical prescribe a medical
intervention for everyone in the public
um and I can kind of see that that
perspective as well that's because the
um therapy was originally a you know uh
designed as an intervention for those
that were ill but that was based on a
module where we only really intervened
when people were in severe illness or in
a bad illness I mean look at it this way
I mean a lot of this comes from the fact
that the very model that we have for
supporting mental health is based on
like a tertiary treatment level so if
you look at this so one of the biggest
issues you have is waiting lists for
Mental Health Services child and adult
Mental Health Services have you know
several year weights in some cases two
or three year weights to be seen now
um I've you know I work alongside with a
lot of the you know the psychiatrists
and then the mental health nurses who
head up uh cams and so on and as they
will say that model was designed to
treat severe mental illness it wasn't
designed for early intervention it
wasn't designed for prevention and so on
so a lot of these tools and treatments
we have were made with that thought in
mind now what we're trying to shift
towards in this country is early
intervention and ideally prevention of
illness and what we've learned is that
actually therapy therapeutic techniques
when adapted for people to
um you know learn how to process life
learn about themselves learn how to deal
with
um instances and relationships and
challenge whatever in whatever isn't
their life can be hugely beneficial it's
not just about I've got PTSD I've got a
huge trauma or I was attacked at some
point or whatever it might have been yes
of course it's got its place there but
for everyone we all experience micro
traumas we have all had a past there's
always been challenges and there's
always stuff that we can we can learn so
yeah I think that that for me is is the
point really it's much better to
intervene early to support people to
learn about themselves to develop
techniques of dealing with life's
challenges than it is waiting until
things are already bad I mean this is a
stat that scared me when I first heard
it that the average time between a
person's first
um mental health symptom or illness
symptom of mental illness to diagnosis
is on average around 10 years a decade
so someone that has so for example me it
makes sense I mean my first symptom of
actual anxiety which was in a way quite
debilitating at the time was at least 12
or 13 years before someone ever told me
have you ever realized that you actually
have uh you know diagnosable levels of
anxiety at people with depression sit
for 20 30 years was actually quite
severe depression in some instances
they're just barely coping but they
spend all this time suffering rather
than improving and I'd much rather
people go early and be told actually on
the very rare occasion actually you
don't need therapy yeah much better to
go than to wait until you've suffered
for 15 years before you go oh I really
could have dealt with this a long time
ago which is actually and let's be
honest that's generally more often the
case I mean I'm not on medication
anymore but I was taking surgery from
anxiety for about 18 months and it saved
my life it saved my life and it changed
my life in fact I don't know if I'd be
here if it wasn't for that medication I
mean I was at the point of very very
dark point at that point and I took that
medication and it saved and changed my
life I'm no longer on it but that
medication allowed me it gave me that
mental energy if you like to make
changes to my own life that basically
mean that I'm here and so you know don't
have any Shame about going to get
therapy or treatment or support if
you're questioning it Go and ask for it
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by heal I've been using huel I've
been a pain customer of huel since 2017
since my fifth year of medical school
when I first discovered it and basically
what it is if you haven't heard of it is
that it is a meal in a shake it got the
perfect balance of carbs and fiber and
proteins and fat and it contains 26
different vitamins and minerals all you
do is add water or milk to the powder
usually I use water you can shake it up
or you can blend it I prefer to blend
and then it becomes a fantastic option
if you're like me and you're kind of
busy and so you don't really have time
for breakfast or lunch my favorite
version is the heel black edition it's
absolutely sick 400 calories 40 grams of
protein for 400 calories I'm trying to
get hinge and it's actually pretty hard
to find something that has such a high
protein content for such a low calorie
trade-off and so I really like using the
heel black edition to start my mornings
off it's vegan it's gluten-free it's
lactose free the Black Edition is
available in nine flavors my favorite is
salted caramel and I wouldn't recommend
having every single meal heal because
that gets a bit annoying after a while
but it's absolutely fantastic it's like
one of the meals of the day especially
if you're busy and you're gonna kind of
default to something unhealthy otherwise
it's also very affordable so it actually
works out to one pound 68 per meal for a
400 calorie meal which is just
incredible value and actually way
cheaper than other generic protein
shakes on the market and it saves a
bunch of time because it's so quick and
easy to make and so it's particularly
exciting that they're sponsoring the
podcast and actually we had the founder
of huel Julian Hearn who was on the very
first season of the podcast that was a
sick episode that got so many rave
reviews as well anyway if you're
interested in trying out huel then head
over to huel.com forward slash Deep dive
and if you use that URL a it really
helps me out but B you also get a free
t-shirt and also a free Shaker that
comes with your order so go to heal.com
forward slash Deep dive that'll also be
linked down in the video description or
the show notes and thank you so much
heal for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put
twenty thousand pounds in every year up
to twenty thousand pounds and it resets
every April and then all that money can
grow and it's completely tax-free for
the rest of your life and if you want to
sign up for an iso you can sign up for
one completely for free also on trading
212. so if you haven't yet filled up
your eyes allowance or at least put some
money into your Isa for this year that
might be a good step forward also very
excitingly there's a new feature that
they've added to the app which is a
daily interest on your uninvested cash
these interest rates may go up or down
over time as the economic environment
changes but the cool thing is that you
get paid out every single day if you're
into that sort of thing the app also
lets you Auto invest which is a great
thing because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started with investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code Ali Ali it will
give you a totally free share worth up
to 100 pounds it's available on iPhone
and Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode what was the story behind the
anxiety and the Sertraline if you don't
mind sure I I mean
knows with ADHD about six seven months
ago and I look back now and it's like
when you know that you have something
it's like how did I not know how did
anyone else not know my entire life I
mean even if you follow the trajectory
of my life and my life decision making
you think even if you want to talk about
say love Island going on there what a
risk that is
um you know the fact that I chose a e is
my career running around in a e as my
kind of interest if you like the way
that I live my life now it's quite
obvious probably to many that would know
me that I that I have ADHD but I was
younger I was really trying to conform
to a neurotypical life Academia in
school for many the reason it doesn't
fit is because you're basically saying
all of you need to fit into the
structure of Academia and learning
otherwise you're a waste of time
basically yeah so I forced myself to
conform and that's never going to and
you have to kind of shoe fit yourself
into something it's never going to come
without consequences so I found myself
to be a very anxious child as a very
sensitive
and as I went through University I just
found like a lot of things really
affected me perhaps more than I saw
affected others I'd developed a lot of
anxiety around time I'd worry about
other people a lot and I think I got a
lot of anxiety from scenarios
um whereby I was kind of stuck in a
place for a long time and it makes sense
if I you've got ADHD and you're stuck in
a room or in a lecture for several hours
it's not great is it and I think since
I've learned more about the ADHD and
anxieties got better which I think is
part of the reason that I've came off
medications I mean I had on top of that
of course
um you know I lost my brother a couple
of years ago three years ago to Suicide
ad you know I worked throughout most the
pandemic and you know if you'll allow me
to say that then I think and I was one
of a few doctors who really was in the
hospital and sharing what was going on
from the hospital every day and I was
filming full arrange show BBC News was
live on BBC News in the evening I was
working every day and the pressure
people gone what's going on what's
Happening we need to film this we need
to hear from the front line we need you
know can we get a consultant on to talk
with you about this and I all of that
took its toll it really took its toll on
me
um and yeah I I I'm very fortunate
really for that medication I think
what impact did the medication have so
at the point where I called my GP I
remember the day actually
um I was working in any shift and I was
questioning whether I needed help I was
actually I got to the point where I was
so anxious and I might actually start
from this from this idea a lot of the
time we separate anxiety and depression
and I'm sure your mum you said is
consultant psychiatrist would agree with
this as well is that when you've got
severe on the severe end of either scale
the two become so in in intertwined so
if you're severely anxious how can your
mood not be affected how many people
have severe anxiety and they're not low
mood or you know burning out and they're
getting complete lethargy and so on and
vice versa if you're feeling so low in
your mood that you can't lift your mood
make you pretty anxious isn't it it's
pretty anyone listening knows it when
you you wake up and you cannot you feel
so low and you can't lift that mood it's
a pretty anxiety inducing feeling so the
two become really intertwined and I
think I got to the point where I'd
realized I was like is this anxiety
anymore am I is this just severe
depression and anyway I was in a shift
in a e and I was like this is bad and I
walked outside side and I literally rung
the GP practice I was very fortunate
actually that I got an emergency
appointment and I told the GP where I
was at and they said listen you know
you've obviously done so much stuff to
try and improve this I'd done all the
techniques I talked about and it just
wasn't working at that point I was at a
severe end of the scale and I think I
was also experiencing a lot of the grief
about my brother so I started searching
and the first eight weeks were really
hard you know in medical we learn like
warm people the first two weeks
um wow I mean it's literally worse than
you'd even explain and that's two or
three weeks of hell is the only way I
can explain it and you go oh my God I
feel this bad now it's making me even
feel worse and I think the only way and
the only reason it was kind of tolerable
and the reason I got through that is
because I sat down I screenshotted a
load of testimonies and and if you go
online you'll see people sharing kind of
their experiences of going on
medications like Sertraline and seeing
the light at the end of the tunnel I was
like oh my God this person saying it'll
get better I remember sitting there
literally like sobbing away reading it
being like it's going to get better it's
going to get better and thank God it did
it did get better and after eight to ten
weeks
it was like a cloud lifted and all this
gray my whole life just become gray
there was more color like there's color
in the green and all of a sudden I
lifted and it was it was I honestly
that's one of the scariest times of my
life being in a situation where you feel
so bad you can't see a way through and
I'm a very resilient person I might be
very sensitive I might get anxious but
I'm very resilient I've been through a
lot of crap in my life and I am quite
resilient and I really was frightened
during that period of time and I'm very
glad to be
out the other side am I you know you you
always face challenges my mental health
goes up and down at times but I know
that even in the bad times I can get
through and that perspective in life is
very important you know knowing that and
this is a challenge for young people my
brother was 19 when he passed away he
didn't have a perspective perhaps that
dark days don't last forever that they
do pass you know I think one of the
challenges for human beings whatever
they're experiencing this current moment
feels Eternal you know anyone will know
that when you've had something go wrong
you failed an exam that was really
really important or you something bad
has happened someone has died in your
family that you loved you think that
suffering is eternal because it feels
that way we only have the present the
odd the odd I guess dichotomy or the odd
thing about life is that we only have
the present and yet we spend a lot of
time in the future and past but when
we're suffering in the present we're
very bad at remembering that there is a
future and that there might be a future
self that doesn't suffer and I think
that you know I wish you know for my
brother and I I talk about a lot you
know for for everyone I hope to to
realize that even the worst suffering
doesn't last forever got a tattoo here
it says this too shall pass and in my
worst times I read it I remind myself
like it will pass yeah it's like all the
spiritual teachings teach us to live in
the present moment but if that present
moment is very dark that's potentially
an unhelpful place but the odd thing is
is that pain makes us you know you see
you get into a cold shot I have a cold
shower every morning I think I'd really
recommend this one of the things that
really helps
um Center you and to start your day but
just like a cold shower is you know it's
cold a shocks you brings this present so
just pain in a way so pain makes us very
aware of the moment that we are in and
sometimes when that pain is so bad
especially when it's a it's it's an
emotional but almost physical pain all
the time when you're when you're
struggling that much you get so bogged
into the present moment you get so and
you also feel so isolated the cruel
thing about mental illness is that it's
an isolating thing it makes you feel
like you're entirely alone there's a
great word
um that I learned recently called sonder
to sonder and it means to be aware of
other struggles even though you don't
know what the struggles are so it's kind
of the idea that you could be sat in the
train station you know you've got all
these people that are walking past you
and you just stop for a moment and go
all of these people that are walking
past me have challenges in their life
they've had things that have happened
things that might happen things that
might be happening right now someone
might have the worst call of their life
and it's not at all to think like oh I
hope other people are suffering too but
it's an awareness that your own
suffering isn't the only suffering to
happen and there's a sense of like
unloading that comes with that and it's
a similar feeling to when you share a
problem I mean when I told my mum that I
was really really struggling at med
school which was the first time I
struggled with my mental health and it
was one of the best feelings of my life
which is really odd because you think
how could that be a best amazing feeling
but all of a sudden I wasn't carrying
the secret of suffering I was sharing it
and I was like oh
I've shared this and I feel better and
maybe I can get better yeah
what what kind of struggle was it at med
school
um at med school I would just severe I
just I became severely isolated actually
and and that isolation made me feel so
lonely and anxious so I was I went to
Peninsula medical Peninsula medical
school
um extra Plymouth and Truro so I was on
placement down in Truro long way from
family and friends I was away from my
girlfriend at the time and I got into a
really lonely place people go like is
loneliness that bad well if you smoke 15
cigarettes a day it's pretty bad for
your health we all know that loneliness
actually causes more harm to your health
than smoking 15 a day it kills a lot of
people it affects mental health physical
health cardiovascular health human
connection is absolutely vital it's a
reason why the whole chapter in my book
is focused on connection because without
that
it can really really impact us and I
basically lost connection and because of
my lack of connection and therefore
almost lack of purpose in my day I
stopped eating well I slept terribly I
didn't exercise didn't go outside I
actually became more isolated because I
felt lonely I actually became more
isolated and there was like a negative
spiral but it got to the point where I
was really in a bad place and you'd
think well why didn't you go you know
did you go to the med school uh why
didn't you go and speak to someone well
as you know I think in the medical
profession I think it's probably one of
the last frontiers of really bad stigma
I think in terms of mental illness and I
thought you know if I go to the
university and say I'm struggling my
mental health what they're going to do
they're going to hold me back a year
they might pause my studies I thought no
way they'll say Alex you can't be a
doctors you can't look after yourself so
what did I do I stayed silent as a lot
of Med students do
and the suffering got worse until
eventually I realized I couldn't carry
on in that way and thankfully I told my
mum and from that moment of speaking to
her a whole chain of things happened all
of a sudden I didn't feel as alone she
also made a very good point she worked
and works well she used to work in in a
bank so not MediCal at all she said Alex
why would you feel good when everything
you're doing in your day will make you
feel bad and I was like
such a really good point I was like
maybe I should get up at seven in the
morning go to bed at 10 maybe I should
probably eat food that's a bit better
for me in general probably exercise a
good idea I could call my mates and go
and make the trip and see them on a
Saturday you get my idea all of a sudden
I started making changes and at first
and this is why the discipline's
important I saw no change I was like oh
my God I feel just as bad but after kind
of 10 12 16 weeks the cloud started lift
I suddenly started feeling less anxious
I felt more assured I felt better I felt
purpose and all of a sudden I was I was
better and I think that's the first time
a I'd realized oh my God mental health
can just hit anyone and that's the first
time I'd really kind of understood how I
felt that and I went to the GP to talk
about it you know and I think that's
also the first time I really understood
that it does matter this kind of
wishy-washy stuff as I thought before
about kind of self-care I was like you
know what damn it's really important
because you know what if you don't you
can end up in the state that I was in
yeah that's one of the things about
mental health that it seems just like
it's such an invisible thing that can
just strike seemingly at any time and
your life could be going on absolutely
swimmingly and then the next thing you
know you're like you know you never know
you never know I mean you never know
what can happen in life I often say
um the things that we worry most about
aren't the things that come to pass you
know often it's a Tuesday afternoon at
four o'clock when the Sun's shining you
get a phone call that changes your life
that's what happened to me you know I
was sitting down to eat dinner with my
friends you know just come out the
pandemic I was supposed to go back to
Wales to see my family the week later my
phone rang and I have um uh agreement
with my parents that if they are ringing
for the chat for a chat just ring once
say my phone started buzzing now they'd
ring once because often I'm filming
stuff or I'm in meetings or doing
something like this and if they film
once and if they phone once I would just
call them back later but if they ring
twice I know it's really important so if
they run twice now I'd answer
um and the phone was buzzing and buzzing
and I thought oh okay so I answered and
I immediately from the tone of voice I
just said who's died and like that you
know your life my life changed and it
has changed forever so even if you don't
believe that mental health can just or
mental illness can just happen to you
from a state of you know this is creeped
up on me as it does for a lot of people
things just can happen to just send you
down and that's why it's so important to
learn about yourself
to learn about your coping mechanisms to
learn your emergency toolkit like what
you're going to do if something really
bad happens in your life someone passes
away it's likely that everyone's going
to lose loved ones in their life it's
life what are you going to do if that
happens if a bad day happens or say you
lose your job whether it's a financial
crisis or something changes in your life
you have a breakup you need to have some
you need to have a plan in action to
look after yourself and luckily by that
point I had been working on a lot of the
stuff I was in the midst of writing my
first book liberal every day and and I
was using a lot of stuff I'd learned
from med school but also obviously my
experiences and I think without some of
that stuff
an awareness that I you know things can
get better I don't know where I'd be
um so I'd say to anyone look just work
on this stuff make it part of your day
because you know if you're wherever you
are like if you're having your days are
70 and they're quite good did you want
them to be 80 you know build upon it if
you want to be more successful in your
career and you want to achieve more or
whatever it is it will help you it will
help you achieve
[Music]
how did it feel in that moment when when
you got the phone call
I have I mean just think this can't be
real you just think this cannot how how
can this happen to me like how has this
happened you know I was supposed to go
home a week later my brother clear uh
was 19 he had a place at stampton med
school he's going to be a med student
um and he was gone and you know we
didn't we didn't think that he was in
that place he was 19 and fed up after
the pandemic was kind of locked away
quite a lot
but we didn't think he would felt
anywhere near like that and that's the
problem I mean he made a binary decision
right there's a there's very few
decisions in life that irreversible very
very few there's very few decisions that
are truly binary that you cannot claw
back or you can to some extent mitigate
deciding to take your own life is one of
those examples where there is no going
back so he made a decision to leave us
rather than talk to us and say how much
is struggling and when people go like ah
stigma we haven't really fixed it well
why would you make that decision to not
even try and tell us and let us try to
help you you've decided that you'd
rather take this option rather than
share and you know in that moment there
was just such a realization of like wow
like why don't you call me you know why
didn't you give me a phone call you know
I was I was very much talking about
mental health well before that
um before I went on love Island I I used
to spend a lot of time in lewisham
hospital teaching Med students and I
spent a lot of time talking about mental
illness because I said look you guys
come here and you think a e is all about
physical you know car accidents and
heart attacks look at the mental illness
that we see you need to learn about this
stuff you know I'd take them into speak
to patients who are struggling with
mental illness to try and get an
understanding because I think a lot of
the time at med school we just think oh
Psychiatry is just that bit in the
corner you know
um and and I actually made a video about
what to do if you're struggling with
your mental health I made on YouTube
actually like couple of weeks before he
died and you know you think wow why
didn't you call me you know why didn't
you pick up the phone and that's
something I have to live with for the
rest of my life you know
um but yeah I'm here it's ups and downs
in life you have everyone has difficult
times I certainly don't sit here and go
like oh pull me or pity me or anything
like that don't pity me
um uh we're all working through stuff
but please you know if someone's
watching they're struggling just make
that phone call tell someone and do it
early if you're asking the question
you're watching this and you feel
triggered or you think are you listening
to this and you feel triggered and you
just think oh gosh is that me or am I
struggling enough to get help just get
help just talk to someone share in how
you're feeling you know I I wish my
brother had shared how he's feeling a
year before six months before whenever
it all started and we could he'd be here
today I'm I'm confident that with the
right intervention anyone can get
through almost anything
why do you think he didn't chat
I think I think the stigma of it is just
so hard for some people you know there's
an analogy that
um you know as children
um we all begin with this suitcase this
metaphorical suitcase and as things
happen in our life knockbacks things
that are said to us challenges we add
things to the suitcase and a suitcase if
we don't unpack things and we don't deal
with those things we don't share we ask
someone to help us with it then or
someone to carry some of the stuff in
the suitcase and just gets heavier and
heavier and heavier until eventually
you're dragging the suitcase and
eventually you either have to share and
you get to the point where either you
share and ask someone to help you
because it's so heavy or you drop it
eventually it's just too much to bear
but for someone to help you you often
need to ask them you need to open your
mouth and ask for help and I guess at
that point he he decided he couldn't
carry this but he also couldn't you
couldn't carry this any further but he
also couldn't ask for help that's the
reality of it and it happens we lose so
many people every three day days in the
UK a student dies by suicide every three
days Ben West who's another activist in
the space
um uh he's amazing he lost his brother
at a very at a close age in close time
to when I lost my brother and he's
currently working at the moment to get
the government to create legislation of
responsibility around mental health for
universities which you think was obvious
I mean it's a physical responsibility
but there's not currently legislation or
framework around the mental health of
students which I mean this should be
shouldn't there so some of the most
obvious things that there should be but
every three days we lose a student in
this country I know we have a lot of
students that are listening to to to
this uh podcast and it doesn't have to
be that way I think that's the point it
doesn't need to be that way we don't
need to rely on people waiting until
they're at the very sharp end to get
help get help early I mean if I was limp
if I was limping on my ankle you know
was I was clearly limping on my ankle
every day
be like what's going on you're right
let's go and take the doctors you don't
wait 10 years do you but I think with
mental well mental health we often wait
so long so so long
too long
yeah one thing I've heard from a lot of
people
um
and especially if I look at like you
know the YouTube comments in our podcast
community and things where you know
while we would like the stigma to be a
lot less there's still that sense of
well if I get physically injured then No
One's Gonna question my self-worth but
if I am mentally injured or if I'm
saying that I can't cope or whatever the
thing might be oh I'm just being a softy
oh I just can't handle the pressure of
oh I signed up to medical school knowing
it was going to be hard and now I'm here
and I'm buckling under the pressure and
therefore I am deficient rather than I
have I have an illness I have a I have a
disease well you know I think if you've
been through something you really are
something you are somebody because you
survived you've endured I've got a
tattoo in the back of my wrist that says
I endured and people might think oh
that's you know seems silly but I remind
myself you know I am here I've been
through and survived all of my most
challenging days and in many ways you
might look and go well actually you know
I've been through some
very difficult things and yet I am here
but also I experienced difficult days
that nothing really caused them and yet
I'm still here so at med school I felt
lonely but I nothing overtly had
happened to cause how I was feeling at
that time although of course as I said
loneliness is a very is a huge thing and
you know the opposite of of loneliness
is connection
um it is very very important that we all
work towards meaningful connection but
nothing had happened to me but I ended
up in a difficult place and I got
through that and the things I learned
from that experience make me stronger
and more resilient you know I you know
you know if you break a bone then when
the bone rebuilds it builds back
stronger and and and and and there is
like an overcompensation of that bone to
to make it more resilient and I think if
you've been through difficult times
you've got support and you've got back
got yourself back to a better place that
makes you pretty tough you know and the
opposite of that is what trying to
pretend that you're absolutely fine I'd
much rather
if I you know my team I'd much rather
people tell me early that they're
struggling so we can work with them and
help them get into a better place then
struggle on and get to an even worse
place even if you weren't thinking of
this from a ethical perspective and a
moral perspective which you should where
humans should care about each other if
you think about a team you don't want
someone to get the point of breaking
point where it's going to take them two
years to fix themselves and be back
functional surely admit to it early on
and let's get you there everyone goes
through stuff I mean I hate the stat one
in four people have mental illness I'm
like well okay wonderful people get
diagnosed at the doctors
how many people go through bad stuff in
their life everyone goes through bad
stuff something will happen to every one
of us in a life that is difficult that
is challenging you might you might get
you might get failure exams that get
into University you might go through a
really bad breakup you might lose your
job that you loved your dream job you
might not even you might get to a point
where you've nearly achieved your dream
job and then you it all goes wrong and
you can't do it maybe you do get a
physical injury that makes you incapable
of doing your or carrying on doing the
passion that you love difficult things
happen to everybody so I think the
sooner we kind of drop this idea that
only you know that you know it's weak to
admit that you've had a difficult time
just be it's being honest actually
be honest and also what it requires As
Leaders I think within Sports within
politics leaders within the world to
actually be a bit more honest as well
you know people often talk about the
success they don't often talk about
their failures you know to you talk
about it um a lot in in the work that
you do that to get to any end result you
have to go through multiple processes
and learn what processes work learn what
are the weak points of what you're doing
the strengths you have to learn about
yourself you've got to adapt you've got
to discipline all these different things
you have to apply all of those learnings
require failure all of them require you
to mess up I mean how many people are so
lucky they have a business idea that
goes straight to the top and they make a
billion dollar company off a business
idea and they they've not failed at all
along the way absolute rubbish look at
Elon Musk is that he's failed all the
time apparently he's still doing rather
well isn't he the richest man on Earth
again yeah something like that 190
billion or whatever he's worth that's
the one and has quite a lot of haters I
don't know how he deals with it yeah
yeah there's a lot of haters and uh and
I think there's a really good Point
around that as well it's like at what
lengths do you want to be successful
whatever that means I think it's better
to take people along with you to care
about each other care about people's
mental and physical health care about
the team and build something that's
meaningful and an environment where
people can generally talk and get
support and you know share yeah that's
so true yeah we've had this issue a
bunch of times within within our team as
well where someone's been feeling
overwhelmed and has been trying to
plaster over the cracks for like six
months before things like come to
Breaking Point and then turns out that
they hadn't taken a day off for the last
like eight months what yeah and that
comes as a complete shotgun
system would help that yeah it's like
going back to the intelligence if you
sat down with your team and you go
around the room it takes a few moments
they'll say actually a feeling kind of
um you'd have learned about the Amber
six months eight months ago exactly yeah
and you're like why everything will
actually I've worked for eight days in a
row why have you worked eight days in a
row right let's resolve that right
you'll feel green you feel green new for
green right how do you support this
person that feels Amber or red it's a
great if you if you've got if you're
listening you've got a business you use
that technique you know all about ways
about people pour so much money into HR
and think of like all right how do we do
this kind of fluffy stuff to support
well-being of Staff just to have a
system where you can actually ask people
how they're doing and you know if you
listen ask ask good questions and listen
to the answers and you'll find that a
lot of the time the solution presents
itself those are good
um is it so just to zoom in on red Amber
green is it like uh red Amber green with
a with a reason or just purely the word
or like how does it work so so if you
think about emotional literacy a great
way to teach children emotional literacy
is just a name just say how do you feel
I feel you can use whether you can use
cloudy rainy or sunny if you want but
red Amber green is something that we're
all brought up with this idea of traffic
lights even if you don't drive you learn
about the Green Man and the red and
you've learned yeah we all learn it's
pretty Universal so I think the most
useful thing is to say two things one
what color you identified to I Feel Red
Amber green and just a sentence or so of
why and if you feel green why why do you
feel green well today I've completed a
task I did my gardening I got a bit of
exercise I slept well last night and you
are cognitively and subconsciously
um establishing and reaffirming the
things that help you feel good you know
we've got two parts of our brain broadly
haven't we got the conscious mind or two
parts of my mind we've got a conscious
mind and our subconscious mind our
conscious mind is only about five ten
percent of what's going on right most
stuff is just running along all the time
subconsciously like you're not thinking
about how you're sitting the whole time
yeah when you drive your location if I
asked you about how what Corners you
took you wouldn't even know you're
thinking about the radio and all this
kind of stuff the only time you click
out of automatic pilot mode of driving
is when you see a horse in the distance
with a rider on top you have to make
decision I have to break or I have to
drop back or I need to overtake slowly
then the conscious mind Clicks in but
most the time it's subconscious but the
thing is you have to train your
subconscious and if your subconscious
has been trained through childhood to
think there's one way of being and
that's the only way of being or this is
the way I'm going to be and we're just
going to tick along in the background
then let your conscious mind makes a
decision to retrain the subconscious it
never changes
another exercise you talk about is um
sort of Wheel of Life to give yourself a
mental health audit I wonder if you can
elaborate on that yeah so
um one of the one of the biggest things
that I I believe is that you have to you
have to understand to fix any problem
you need to understand what the problem
is first of all you can't find a
solution without knowing the problem is
again going back to medicine is very
hard to treat a patient if you don't
know what's going on and the the wheel
of life is just a useful way to break
down the sections of your life broadly
you know I sat about certain examples
but break it down and then be able to
give a score to that section about how
happy you are that you're in the right
place so it could be like I'm just gonna
say like you know uh physical fitness is
just a random one right and you can give
your scoring something you can give zero
to ten whatever you'd like to use but
give yourself a number or an
understanding on this scale about where
you are have several factors in your
life you could break it down into
finances you can put it into fitness you
can put into mental health you can put
into your hobbies you can put in
whatever you like are you achieving what
you want to achieve in that area or are
you where you want to be and it allows
you to have a general look back and go
well actually do you know what my
physical fitness is pretty pretty good
but actually I don't feel that I'm doing
the things I enjoy in my life I'm not
achieving or doing my hobbies at all and
so it just really helps to zoom out and
then Zoom back into the areas that you
want to want to work on and you know I I
would say like with
um like with the track traffic light
system it's just knowing what's normal
for you and knowing where you want to be
and then putting in place those changes
and you know I use the idea of a toolkit
all the time at the end of the day like
my toolkit will be different to yours
like I will have a different routine I
probably get up at varying different
times there's certain things I'll do my
day might be similar to you or different
to you and just understanding how you
are what you use to have your
maintenance stuff yeah what things build
your mental Fitness and what things are
in your emergency toolkit and I know it
sounds silly but have an emergency
toolkit so on a day where everything
goes wrong what you're gonna do what are
you gonna do to look after yourself you
know because often let's be honest the
default is drinking for most people this
let's be frank I mean the hospital bad
day on the wall what should we do let's
go to the pub or end up drinking the
irony of course is that we use drinking
and it makes most things worse you know
people say oh but alcohol relieves
stress actually a recent study showed
that even drinking free glasses of wine
a week raises your Baseline cortisol
levels which is obviously a hormone we
associate with stress and inflammation
in the body so alcohol isn't that great
for stress it's not actually that great
for anything really so learning what
your good coping mechanisms are going to
be on bad days is as important as your
maintenance day today yeah yeah like um
the The Wheel of Life is one of my
favorite things to to do personally but
also to do as part of a group
um we were in Austin Texas last week and
we did a meet-up for like 100 of our
YouTube Academy students and at the end
of my keynote I was like all right guys
we're gonna do a little exercise bear
with me on this one and we just split
life up into 10 different things and I
just gave them the the 10 categories
everyone's on their phone wrote just a
number on how how aligned they're
feeling with each one people were like
whoa
you know that's that's really helpful
it's like I've realized I'm not spending
enough time with my friends and I just
hadn't realized that until I literally
was forced to give it to give it a
number and so I think exercises like
that that you would find in
you know life coaching books and things
like that that might seem a bit uh weird
especially for an uh a somewhat
intelligent audience
um I remember the first time we did we
we did The Wheel of Life it was in our
fifth year of medical school and it was
a session called how to be a successful
doctor where the twist of the session
was that you know our tutor doctor later
craps basically said that for Cambridge
Medical students it's almost a given
that success is becoming you know
getting that like oh intense like
ranking in your FPS or in your sd3
applications or becoming the Regis
professor of physic but actually there
are loads of different ways to be
successful whatever that means to you
and he handed out this Wheel of Life
exercise and like half of the class
absolutely loved it half of the Year
group the other half was like what the
hell is this this is a total waste of
time I can't believe I came and follow
those people if you follow those two
halves and you see who was most
successful at the end and what in
actually most ways you develop that
you'd measure success the group that
enjoyed it would have been most likely
for successful not because size is
amazing but because they were open to
new ways of thinking and towards
introspection people that are that are
Steph that don't want to think of new
ideas they don't want to think outside
the box or understand they might be
Merit in things they don't understand
are often the ones that perhaps don't
end up where they want to be and I've
seen that in my life I mean it's only
anecdotal I'm not backing I'm not saying
there's that I've got evidence for that
but in my experiences generally those
that are adaptable in life are able to
get the most out of it and it's exactly
the reason that I want schools to focus
a little bit less on academic results
and a bit more on building well-rounded
resilient
um you know
children there are people that are able
to work in teams they're able to adapt
to adversity they're able to overcome
and able to find and are able to look
for the positive and useful thing like
even if you're doing something so if you
put me in a I decided to go along with
friends a random thing like salsa or
whatever and being able to go along
while I'm here for an hour let's get
something out of this let's use as a
confidence building exercise rather than
going to something going this is a waste
of time I don't want to do it you're
going to gain you're not gonna gain
anything if you go with attitude if you
go to the attitude to try and learn
something you might Justin to use um the
reason I think that this stuff is also
important and the reason that actually
understanding where you're at right now
is so important is to use a an old Arrow
very much overused adage you know
knowledge is power it's absolutely true
like often we feel feelings of
discomfort we don't know what what the
reason is like why am I even if you
everyone knows the feeling of being
angry and you've munched away on a class
and you're probably a bit hungry off
your therapy
um yeah you know hungriness is something
we all under stand but how often do you
walk around hangry and you don't know
it's because you're hungry and it's
actually a girlfriend your mate goes
have you eaten you seem hangry you go oh
my God I am really angry you thought you
were just not you thought you were
literally annoyed about this random
thing that happened this train that's
late but actually you were hungry so
we're not very good we're good we're
good at feeling discomfort yeah we're
not often very good at knowing where
discomfort comes from so if you're
feeling not at ease in your life then
working out where that comes from is
your primary yeah you know that's the
most important thing where does that
come from is it because I'm lonely do I
lack good connection in my day today am
I hyper connected online the digital
space but not really having a meaningful
connection face to face or am I actually
just sleeping like crap you know a lot
of people feel really rubbish a lot of
the time and a lot of it is for a lot of
people it's because it's just don't
sleep enough they they don't sleep and
um if you sleep badly everything else
goes wrong you know so just just having
a little think about where where does
this feeling come from where does this
discomfort from all right we're going to
take a very quick break from this
episode to introduce our sponsor which
is brilliant.org I've been using
brilliant for the last several years and
they're a fantastic online platform for
courses in maths and science and
computer science brilliant is a
fantastic resource for anyone who wants
to develop new skills but especially if
you work or you want to work in a STEM
related field it's an absolute
no-brainer for being able to level up
your knowledge of these topics brilliant
has an enormous library of courses that
cover all sorts of topics and the
courses are particularly good because
they take a very first principles
approach to the topic that they're
trying to teach like it's not just that
they spoon feed you information and
expect you to memorize it like often we
were taught in school but it's more like
they teach you a principle and then you
apply it with some interactive puzzle or
game or activity of some sort and then
you teach you a little bit more and then
you apply a little bit more and it turns
into this really interesting kind of
engaging teaching system which is
actually similar to the way that we were
taught at Cambridge when I was in med
school there where you learn a little
bit and then you apply it and then you
learn a bit more and you're generally
paired with an expert in the field and
you kind of learn together and figure it
out and build the building blocks of the
knowledge in your own mind over time
rather than kind of being spooned of
fire hose of information and I expected
to regurgitate it one of my favorite
courses I'm brilliant other than all the
stuff on computer science which is like
my specialist subject outside of
medicine but they've got a really cool
course on scientific thinking and this
course explores the laws of physics and
engineering and just helps you generally
get an understanding of how the world
Works brilliant are also constantly
updating their lessons and courses so
for example they released a new course
on crypto back when that was blowing up
so people could understand that they
have a really interesting course on
neural networks and how they work which
feeds into all the artificial
intelligence stuff and it's just a
generally great way of keeping up with
all these Topics in the field of stem so
if any of that stands up your street
then do head over to brilliant.org
forward slash deep dive and if you're
one of the first 200 people to hit that
link which is also in the video
description and in the show notes then
you'll get 20 off the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
and let's get right back to the podcast
for me one thing I've really realized in
the last in the last few months which
I've you know it's taken me 28 years to
realize this uh that like sometimes I
feel like this like low level like level
of agitation and I realized it's just
because I need a Wii and I've just been
holding it and I'm just like oh that's
it all right you know what let me just
take a break wasn't there a study once
you're the audio you're the expert in
productivity was there a wasn't there a
study that like found that people needed
a Wii during their exams they got
they've got better marks
probably you're like so focused I gotta
answer this question and I used to try
and use that in med school exams when I
needed a week I thought right I need to
just like harness this feeling right now
because apparently it'll make me better
I'll remember the anatomy of whatever
one of the one of the truths that you
speak about um in the book is about
boundaries you're right having
boundaries is key to mental Fitness and
lots of us need to reclaim our lives
from the ex from the expectations of a
society that never says no
um yeah what are your what are your
thoughts and boundaries I feel like this
is something I struggle with that I've
realized in the last couple of weeks
well that's when you say that because I
think um you know you're you are you're
you're you're you're a very articulate
expert in productivity and what I mean
by that is that I think you articulate
Theory fantastically well and you also I
think you also um you're very skilled at
making sometimes quite complex ideas
um I think uh uh achievable and almost
like engageable I know the word is for
for most people I I know that one of the
things that you've talked about in the
past is like working like working
prioritizing but also working out where
you put your energy right and time this
concept of like you have a resource
which is your time you know you talk
about all this all the stuff and I and I
think that you know we innately all of
us
feel as human beings that we need to say
yes to everything and that we need to
share this resource with everyone and I
think one of the things that again is a
bit of a bit of a con or I don't know
the word is it's a bit of a misleading
thing to say is like we need to be yes
people be a yes man you know that felt
like when I was growing up that was like
the buzzword be a yes person okay and
true I did have my friend Freya saying
you need to try and do things more and I
think in a way advice is great but it
also LED that me to do and say yes to
almost everything and you know when I
when I um I can pay basically I the
reason I became mental health and master
is because I went around and spoke to
all of the experts and leaders in this
space as well as young people as well as
teachers and everyone and I came up with
a quite agreeable rest list of all the
things that we thought needed addressing
and this was kind of like you know
broadly these are the big areas you need
to work on and I basically use social
media to bang on number 10's door when
they opened the door and say and I said
this is the things that we found I
wasn't trying to really do anything
other than make them realize what what
we were what needed to be sorted I
didn't have an idea that I was going to
be an ambassador in this kind of space
but they said look you know you you're
working with a lot of these Charities
and in areas and whatever why didn't you
represent them and you know work
alongside Us in the sense that share
with us what where people think you know
work needs to be done the problem was
when I took on the role everyone came
knocking on my door saying this this
idea have you seen this research can you
fund this can you find out about this
can you make this happen can you
everyone wanted a piece of me and at
first I said yes to everything but what
I quickly learned is that if you say yes
to everything you make a tiny bit of
almost almost undetectable impact across
a load of different things and nothing
is even almost measurable in terms of
impact whereas if you go do not rather
than doing
300 things
actually quite badly and also doing
actually the negligible difference if
you take together all that time from all
those things and you add them up and
stack them up on top of each other in
two or three aspects or even ideally one
aspect you make a massively measurable
amount of change and that's why all of a
sudden after about a year I said you
know what this thing I really care about
is early support hubs I want to have an
early support hub for under 25 year olds
in every community in the country where
they don't wait two years you have
walk-in support access to therapy wrap
around support so they're looking at
your life as a whole you talked about
that life wheel but that kind of idea of
working out where does this young person
need support what can we do is it
actually Financial struggles is it
education is it is it the fact that this
person might have ADHD and they've not
been diagnosed like are they lonely how
do we get this person back into sport or
whatever it might be all of a sudden all
of my energy challenged into this and
I've made I think quite a huge amount of
progress in this area well there's two
areas that there's two things I want to
achieve this year and I hope I'll get
there first is early support Hub funding
I need 200 million pounds to fund
190 hubs that'll cover each health
district in England my plan with them or
our plan as a coalition would be to then
roll that out so you'd have that as a
starting point and use that as a model
to roll it out the other thing that I
want to do is to create a legislative
framework in the workplace so at the
moment there is virtually no legislative
legislation around mental health and
workplace you have to have a certain
number of physical first aiders
um per Workforce number so for every 50
people you need one physical first aid
and I want there to at least be parity
with mental health which seems pretty
obvious given the main killer of under
35 year olds is suicide so those are the
two things I want to achieve and by
identifying those two things it means
you can focus all of your energy into
achieving that and we have a saying
amongst the team
um
is it essential
and it's a very simple way that I
approach most things and I'm here sat
with you because I think this is
essential I think this is a great way
for me to speak to a lot of uh young
people as well as those within
businesses and so on I can speak to a
lot of people on this podcast a about
mental health and why I think it's
important to everyone and also I can
talk about the things I'm trying to
achieve I'm trying to you know people
are hearing hopefully about this these
two Targets and they might go away and
think oh do you know what if I see a
petition around that or if I you know if
I've got anywhere I can support him
maybe I'll try and help towards those
two goals so it's essential for me but
if it's not essential I now say no and
that can be really hard at first and
that's where the boundary chapter
started it's like I realized that I say
yes to everything and achieve nothing
most the time that's how I felt I was
cheating yes to everything achieving
nothing when I decided to start saying
no to almost everything I started saying
yes to things I thought authentically
want to say yes to do it too and I
actually started achieving things all of
a sudden I had cognitive space creative
space energy and time to do things you
know we do something now
um with my diary my diary was
crazy it was absolutely it still is I
mean it's it's it is packed jam-packed
months in advance but what we started
doing is clearing weeks in the diary not
for annually that's different times with
clear weeks whole weeks in the diary
which are just breathing space for
creativity and allowing space for ideas
and things to just happen and you know
what those weeks are when I achieved by
far the most we start a week as a team
with nothing planned
and it feels a really uncomfortable
feeling oh my God you've got to have the
dice all this stuff to do no have that
week free to breathe and you'll find you
do so much more in that week and Achieve
so much more than the weeks that you've
diarized everything and it's the same
concept say no to stuff create space and
you'll find that you'll do so much more
use that in your own life as well
boundaries are not just for the
workspace you know how often do you end
up going to a social event or doing
something or saying yes to a party or
wedding you didn't want to go to there's
nothing worse than wasting time the most
the most valuable asset you have is time
you know and and everything feeds into
that and everything feeds off that if
you spend time you ain't getting any
receipt for it there's no there's
certainly no refund for your time
there's nothing worse than feeling that
you've wasted your time and there's two
things I'd say
have boundaries so you don't waste it
and make sure that you spend the time
with your loved ones and doing the
things that either work towards your
goals or build up your enjoyment your
hobbies or whatever work towards one of
those
um slices of the pizza on your wheel
um and the other point is if you are
going to spend time and you said yes to
doing something really commit to it you
know if you decided at the moment do you
know what I do think it's worth so let's
make a joke out of it today if I decide
I was going to come on this podcast I'm
going to come today I might as well come
and get the most out of it and really
make this an enriching time than
dragging myself through it you know so
if you're going to commit to something
what I'm saying is if you're going to
say you're going to do something do it
like if you're gonna promise someone
you're gonna do something give them your
best and the only way you can do that
though is to allow yourself to have
enough energy to do that if you promise
to do everything yeah you won't do
anything and a great catchphrase and I
talk about in the mind manual about
having ways to deal with
um situations where you need boundaries
so I've been six months over or six
months alcohol three hours of yesterday
which I'm proud of
um important to say I don't have
addiction I'm speaking from perspective
I made a Health Choice I don't I don't
compare myself to those that suffer from
addiction it is very much you know um
something that I decided to do because I
felt that I'd be happier without it and
healthier and so on but it's still a
challenge it's still hard not to drink
because the society is kind of
constructed around the consumption of
alcohol almost in every different facet
and way and ironically if you're trying
to be productive probably the biggest
thing that will be stopping you
achieving your goals will be alcohol you
know almost for every single person if
you drink alcohol and you want to do one
thing to improve your productivity
outcomes your health your relationships
your Fitness anything just stop drinking
it's one of the best things that you can
do but people ask you to drink all the
time so having an anchor phrase is
really useful and sometimes even just an
awareness of how you're going to respond
to that like people go and say Alex
doing a drink I just say I don't drink
but thank you or I go say would you like
a drink I would say at the bar so we are
at a restaurant what would you like to
drink I'd say I'd like to have um a
whatever name of the drink it might be
in my sparkling water or I want whatever
it is don't allow for space of
conversation if you don't want to have
that around drinking and if someone
questions you and says oh do not drink
say oh no I don't drink
if you don't create space for the
conversation it doesn't happen some
people will be curious because they're
so be curious and say oh that's really
interesting how come you stop drinking
and then you can have that conversation
if you'd like to but have boundaries
over what you share you don't have to
explain away everything the same way if
someone says um Ali I'd love you to come
to uh this restaurant next week we're
going to have dinner so oh thank you so
much I really appreciate asking but not
this time we'll do it another time or
just no thank you you don't have to give
excuses and often when you give excuses
it just feels so and authentic it's not
authentic just say you don't want to
it's fine your time is precious and it
is the keyword is your time suspend it
in the way that you want to but a great
anchor phrase I find for work stuff and
I don't know what you use but you know I
get asked to do lots of different things
if I am absolutely certain in my gut
that it's the right thing to do I'll say
yes to it but if there is even a Shadow
of Doubt that I think this might not be
the right thing to do I need to think on
it I say ask me in 24 hours you know I'd
be sat in the room here my my um EA and
I'll say to ask me 24 hours she puts it
24 hours next to whatever the question
is could you ask me again tomorrow it
allows your brain time to think about am
I making a reactionary decision or am I
or am I actually uncomfortable with this
another piece of advice I'd give is
never make never make an important
decision in fact if you can avoid any
decision from a position where you've
just achieve something or succeeded or
want something or something you've
really lost or something bad that's
happened if you're on a high of success
you'll often take on more things because
your endorphins are pumping you're like
oh do you know what
um I've done this Masters let's do a PhD
yeah
don't make a decision once you've just
achieved something yeah also never make
a decision when you're reeling from A
Loss when things have gone wrong we have
a context of like again going back to
that point this is forever the suffering
this pain that's awfulness is forever
you're much more likely to make a bad
decision allow breathing spaces most
things do not have to be decided in the
moment you're in other than what kind of
coffee do you want to drink when you're
stood in the cafe most things
can have time you don't have to commit
to things too quickly yeah the boundary
thing is something I struggle with so
much why do you struggle with that I
thought I'm surprised you say that
because given how much you talk about
there's some surprise it's very honest
if you'd share it but I'm surprised that
you struggle with I think uh because I
have a people-pleasing tendency and so
whenever someone asks me something if
they're asking me in person or even
often if they're asking me on message
and it's someone that I know
in some way personally I will feel this
strong compulsion to say yes to the
thing can I give you a phrase please I
would love yeah any tips I'm at capacity
it's one of the best phrases you can use
that I think is pretty well understood
by everyone and it can be taken in any
people understand and go there either
capacity in terms of they don't feel
they have the energy for it they are too
busy they're just politely saying I
can't and I use that phrase and I've had
DMS from people I just say I'm really
sorry that sounds brilliant I don't even
say it's actually Delight I don't say
I'm sorry anymore I say you know thanks
so much for asking I really appreciate
it but I'm at capacity at the moment
capacity I would use it because you
can't be offended by that how can you be
offended by someone saying they're at
capacity that capacity means you can't
take more and I think people really
understand that I found no one has ever
come back and said oh wow no one has
ever done that I'm at capacity and you
know what there you go you said about
your therapy that's a great thing to
what why are people pretty pleaser yeah
all of that stuff I think why do you
think you're a people for Lisa I've been
reading a good book called No More Mr
Nice Guy uh which is very good is
written by some therapist who deals with
sort of people pleasing tendencies in
men and that book just speaks to me so
much because he talks about how a lot of
Early Childhood experiences or can
contribute to a child feeling as if
they're not enough as they are and they
have to perform or do something or get
that perfect grade or whatever and then
that cycle of perfectionism becomes part
of their being and so when someone asks
you for something you're like oh yeah
you know I want to be a good person a
good person says yes two things and is
not selfish and any amount of self-care
gets rid of selfish and selfish is seen
as bad and so all of these different
patterns add up to create this feeling
of
oh yeah I'm gonna say yes even though I
don't really want to say yes to the
thing it's uh it's something that's
shared by a lot of people actually I
think and
um you know you're right it's so much of
it's from childhood I mean I had Parents
um I think it's fair to say my dad was
quite strict
um I was the first I was the first child
I think my parents were kind of from
that area and I grew up in I guess 90s
early 2000s when I think it was kind of
strict Parenthood it was that kind of
time
um success means doing well at school
and yeah I had the same feeling I think
you know our perfectionism wanting to be
the best anything from the best but the
best is not great and worst of all it's
actually terrible if you're not the best
and I very much unearned those things
but it's taken a lot of work and I still
come those Tendencies often still come
back at times and I have to go oh
actually where does that come from why
am I feeling that way and actually can
make you um it can make you feel two
things number one that if you don't
agree to do something because someone's
asking you that you're a bad person that
you're a failure but also can make you
really start comparing to others and
thinking what if I'm not doing as much
as that person or that person that I'm
not successful I mean one of the things
I think is fascinating is that
we slightly not patronizingly but we
slightly go off social media yeah
um comparison culture and social media
just about body images and six-pack it
isn't is it you speak to a lot of um
professionals they'll go oh yeah but you
know I feel comparison you know I had a
psychiatrist tell me a few months ago
um I obviously won't say who adult was
said they find it really hard and find
it triggering online because they see
other consultant psychiatrists
presenting more papers or doing more
conferences or writing or you know
getting published in this article so you
know we are a little bit like oh it's
about flash cars and Six Packs yeah
there are it is a comparison is about
every metric of comparison human to be
human is to compare so we'll compare
anything
um yeah but actually it's a huge thing
in in the workspace as well productivity
I mean there's a huge balance of
productivity and what's productive
what's toxic what's you know if you're
sharing doing a run at five through in
the morning yeah are you sharing that
because
you're celebrating within yourself or
you're just sharing because you're
showing other people that you're doing 5
30 in the morning what impact does that
have on other people and I'm not saying
it's wrong I mean there's so many ways
and I share things like okay I shared
that my children's book one children
children's book of the Year why am I
sharing that you could dig into all
these things you know I'm very proud
that I that I did that and so on
but there is a that we have to think a
little bit sometimes about why we're
posting stuff but also if we're seeing
something if we're reacting negatively
why are we doing that because sometimes
you know someone's posted something with
the best intentions but it's fad a
negative effect on you that person's not
trying to have a negative effect and
you've got to work out why where does
your reaction come from yeah is it
because you're now beating yourself up
because you didn't work harder on
something yeah when actually you're
already doing so much I I think that
that's really important part of
boundaries in life is around all that
stuff it's also a social media I mean
the average person spends between three
and four hours a day on social media
that's a huge amount of time make sure
you you'll know why you're using it's
the first thing like like you know if
it's to make yourself laugh that is a
valid reason but just know what reason
it is doesn't have to I'm using it to
propel my business and to start them it
can just be when a giggle looking at
cats that uh whatever cat that is dog
videos whatever it is doesn't matter
just know while you're using it don't
get sucked into it and also just be
careful if you're having negative
reactions to stuff then you know
moderate who you follow call your
following you know if you're following
people that trigger you don't follow
them like follow people that inspire you
probably one of the biggest things I'll
say you know how often do you do people
open up their phones in the morning and
get triggered by something you know
create boundaries but one of the truths
in the book is you are enough and in
that section you talk a lot about
imposter syndrome which is something
that like whenever I do any kind of poll
on the internet loads of people struggle
with imposter syndrome I wonder can you
riff Riff on imposter syndrome yeah so
you know the human mind is negatively
biased and the reason it's negatively
biased because it's protective mechanism
you know when you look at
um human neurodevelopment in fact human
development at all we haven't really
changed much in thousands of years we we
really haven't changed think of how
different the world was in 300 years ago
let alone thousands of years our brain
and the reason it's negatively biased is
because
it's a protective mechanism like if if
for example
um we walk out into that we walk into
the forest and it's full of wolves and
those wolves could kill us uh we get
away from that situation and survive the
next time we walk into the forest we're
going to be very weary and think
negatively there's probably wolves in
there because it protects us you know
that's
that is an important protective
mechanism as is anxiety you know
adrenaline and all these things you know
it's a fight or flight to deal with a
problem that's in front of us and you
know we retain memories because memories
allow us to learn from the past and make
decisions in the present that make our
future more certain you know our
self-preservation is like the number one
goal for humans as individuals on the
race we need to survive and so we
survive by learning sticking together
broadly acting in the present but
worrying about the future the problem is
that modern day Society not for everyone
I'm talking broadly for a lot of people
we perhaps don't have that kind of fight
or survive or life or death in every
moment of Our Lives most moments that
we're sat here now quite safely you know
we're not under immediate threat sat
here but our minds as we said have not
changed in thousands of years and so
they will fixate on things the
negatively biased mindset will always
fixate on worries and it will spend time
ruminating on the past where people talk
about depression is because of a
rumination in the past and anxiety being
our Obsession of the outcomes of the
future but we're living these
experiences in the present moment and
the problem is with imposter syndrome
and why everyone experiences it because
that negatively biased mind is trying to
protect us from outcomes negative
outcomes the problem is is that
sometimes it is overbearing into our
detriment so
um we might think oh I I can't give this
uh talk on
um alcohol's effect on the on the liver
in front of all these people I'm an
imposter actually that person you might
be a registrar in liver studies you
spent the last six months reading the
papers you've just published an article
around you know you are an expert is
what my point is but yet we feel still
feel the inner child often in times
vulnerability when negativity takes over
we actually go back to our inner child
and we forget everything that we've
experienced we go back to that
vulnerable state of like oh my gosh like
what am I doing here I mean I remember
my first day in Kings on the wards and I
went to prescribe paracetamol I had a
sudden moment of panic of genuinely like
what am I doing here get me out here I
can't remember the dose of paracetamol I
literally turned to the nurse I was like
oh my God I'm feeling really bad like in
like I feel just like and she knew
almost she was like it's fine it's just
the first few days you're just feeling
you know you feel imposter a little bit
like that's it happens and it's the
negative mindset now I I think
people wonder oh wow would be great to
get rid of imposter syndrome I don't
think it would entirely because you
become an egomaniac and think you're
amazing everything it's great to have a
perspective of like I'm good but not
perfect yeah or I'm valid or worthy of
this but maybe I'm not perfect I can
still learn that's really important but
if you let a imposter syndrome can take
over your life it can prevent you doing
anything and I almost think it's worth
remembering I have a saying and I always
say to myself what is the worst that can
happen I know that sounds if I'm going
to bring you know lightning to be struck
on me it's not what I mean and it's not
even a throwaway of like oh what's the
what's gonna happen I don't care that's
not what I mean
I literally mean what is the worst case
here so if I'm getting up to do a talk
um about mental health you know you
talked about when you
um you know you've done many Keynotes
but say doing Keynotes uh on YouTube or
productivity or business in front of a
lot of people you might think oh gosh
I'm doing this they might be like quite
good entrepreneurs in the room I'm
speaking about this what's the worst
that can happen genuinely you make an
absolute fool yourself that's the worst
that can happen and like really the
worst case you make an absolute fool
yourself partly you probably haven't but
you might feel that you have you're
still alive you're still recoverable you
can still be a successful business
person you can still have a valid
enjoyable life you have to laugh with
your friends you can eat dinner
afterwards we often think that the
outcomes are so much worse than they are
in most scenarios
they're not truly the case and so I
think it's sometimes applying a bit of
perspective to imposter syndrome gets
you
gets you past that mindset you know I
had it I mean I sat down with Boris
Johnson when he was prime minister I was
in Margaret Thatcher's room in number 10
down street right and the picture of
Margaret Thatcher was above his head and
he was sat there and I was presenting to
him everything that I'd found out from
all the experts I'd spoke to from the
Charities from the Royal College of
higher trade kind of garnered all this
kind of stuff that we'd put together and
I was taking it to him imagine how much
of an imposter I felt but I literally
said to myself because I felt I felt it
coming on before I went in the room and
I thought I was feeling almost panic and
I thought what's the worst gonna happen
yeah I'm in this room for half an hour
max it'll be done worst case scenario I
never come anywhere near this place ever
again I just run away it's fine I'll
surviving which is the same as what uh
most people's position is already that
yeah they're not going to be a really
good so the worst case scenario is like
you go back to you know you just gotta I
think sometimes imposter syndrome it's
asking yourself what's the worst that
can happen it's realizing that everyone
feels I have never met anyone in my life
I'm sure there are a few people out
there but I'd argue that probably
they're not in the spectrum of normal
that that most people will feel at
certain times that they are an imposter
most people feel that and therefore feel
a degree of comfort and also realize you
would you know I remember I remember
once um doing um as an SHO do an OBS and
guinea I was doing a night shift with a
consultant new consultant she's like I
feel like a complete imposter I was like
what you've done all this training
you're literally I just watched her do a
surgery she's literally so skilled I
mean she was so slick she was just like
she bossed it I was like you feel like
an imposter she's like yeah absolutely
and I had this real realization I was
like wow everyone I've just seen this
person it's probably one of those
skilled people
but in life and they're smashing this
and they feel like an imposter you
realize everyone feels like it it's not
that bad a thing when those feelings
come on board look for evidence look for
evidence for the fact your imposter then
write down all the evidence of the fact
you're not and I will nine times out of
ten you'll find out that you're not an
imposter and you know what if perhaps it
does highlight somewhere that is an
issue then deal with it say you're doing
a new rotation in medicine and a new
rotation is in something really well say
you're doing like um HIV as a rotation
okay first of all you're not going to be
like taking over and having to know
everything about HIV so often remember
imposter syndrome a lot of the time it's
because you think suddenly like
everything's on you or like the world
will collapse it's not gonna collapse if
you don't know anything about HIV you'll
go in there the consultant will assess
your kind of knowledge capabilities
they'll always have be there to guide
you and so on but it might highlight the
fact that you haven't looked up HIV for
a long time you need a bit of work and
revision so always look at things and
think what is this highlighting why do I
feel this way what's the average
foreign to the contrary and actually if
there is a learning outcome like maybe
before I start HIV uh rotation in a few
weeks time I'll spend four or five hours
reading up on HIV and learning and all
of a sudden you feel bolstered and you
feel better
I suspect if you asked
99.9 of doctors would you write a book
called The Mind manual they would say
hell no I'm not allowed to write a book
like that until I'm at least a
Psychiatry trainee if you ask 99 of
Psychiatry trainees they'd probably be
like no I've got to wait until I'm a
consultant if you also consulted the
wheel and I've I've got to wait until
I'm like the Regis professor of
psychiatry in adolescent medicine and
even then I'm not qualified to write a
book called The Mind manual
there are so many doctors who have to
have this issue but what seems you've
gone over it well when do you know and
also you know when do you when do you
stop and I guess the point is is like
if I didn't write this book and already
it's been out a few weeks and I've had
the messages from people that it's
helped if I didn't write this book
because I was almost restricted almost
by ego but I'm preventing something that
will help other people
because of ego regardless of his mind or
other people you know I wrote the book a
better day and I had a number of
messages now you know I've won
children's book of the year for that
book I I've I've got thousands of
messages from parents whose children
it's helped what if I didn't write that
book think how many thousands of kids
we've not helped and I think sometimes
the greatest shame is that people have
so much to give people have so much to
share and they don't do it because
they're worried about what other people
will think so think about how many
psychiatrists out there could share
knowledge they think to them is like not
that big but to other people if you
don't know it you don't know it he knows
that old concept you don't you don't
know what you don't know think how much
they could help with the people if they
didn't feel so restricted by it you know
all of a sudden we're seeing doctors
like you know you you myself Dr Karen
we've seen Dr Julie
um you know we've seen so many people
starting to go hang on
why are we not sharing this no one owns
Health there's no it's like I own health
you don't own it you know you also don't
get to decide whether the people Help
other people do you know what I mean
don't be afraid of that of course act
within uh boundaries you know I
basically for this book it's a it's
a split between my own experiences in
life and and the stuff that I share is
all evidence-based stuff I mean there's
doctors we learn to what do we learn we
learn to critically evaluate and analyze
information and come up with some
reasons basically what we do we see
pretty much it can basically use
evidence to look at a patient put it all
together and come out with an outcome
and you know I I yeah I I really think
that um the world is changing I think
doctors are realizing that we don't have
to be so insular and it's not like only
one way to do something you know I
really encourage doctors if you want to
if you want to have a long career in
medicine trying to have hobbies outside
at the minimum but also have other
fields of Interest I think you know I
went and did um I did level three PT
personal training because actually in
medicine we don't learn a lot about
Fitness physiology and the facts of
exercise on the body and if I'm going to
talk a lot about mental and physical
health I want to understand those things
I learned so much I literally was like
oh my God I didn't know this stuff and I
benefited from going away and like
immersing myself I've got a friend that
does um is a GPU does yoga as well and
they bring so much of the learnings from
yoga into the GP room because what does
yoga teach you teach about presenteeism
it teaches you about mindfulness it
teaches about you know dealing with
anxiety and depression and therefore
this person has a fantastic insight to
help their patients and what a GPC a lot
of mental health issues so look for ways
to enrich that you enjoy don't be
ashamed about stepping outside of like
the OST hierarchy or whatever whatever
and if you ever get attacked for it I
can tell you that most of the time it's
from a position of jealousy it's an
absolute fact it's from a position of uh
of jealousy if there is truth in what
they say take it on board and learn
about it you know with this book I mean
I said to before I started I taught this
book apart three times this is the my
manual 0.3 or whatever you call 3.0
because I tore it apart to make sure if
I'm going to call it the my manual it'd
probably be a damn good book and I'm
proud of it it is a damn good book and
I've had psychiatrists and GPS and
doctors tell me that it's a good book
um so don't be afraid you know give
things a go don't let imposter syndrome
prevent you from living your life
because one day you'll be dead and it'll
be done anyway you know we're alive it's
often this is called the Deep dive
podcast so it's fine
um you know we're alive for a blink of
an eye you know the the Earth has been
around the human race been around for
like 300 000 years something like that
um the Earth has been around for a
couple of billion years right it's a
long time got a billion years we measure
time in 2023. that's how much we measure
modern time
2023 the average human lifespan is 70 80
years
it's literally blink of an eye and let
me tell you if you're worried about
things you're suffering problems and
you'll be spending a lot of time
thinking about your problems just
remember in three generations and only
them now in two generations one
generation you probably won't even
remember your problems right now in 20
years let alone you might remember
roughly what you're thinking about but I
bet you most things you worry about you
won't remember
but in two generations time No One's
Gonna remember so just just free
yourself from the constraints of that
sometimes you know if you want to write
a book write it write the book if you
want to try a new hobby do it if you
want to leave the career in you now
regardless of medicine whatever whatever
you're doing if you want to leave your
career and you want to try something new
you want a new challenge or you feel
that you're not in the right place that
you belong somewhere else or that you
want to try something you then do it
because life is short nice a certain
mates such inspiring stuff I love it um
um happiness is an inside job
what do you mean by that so I talk about
happiness in the book slightly
begrudgingly because I think
we try and convince people that we
should try and be happy and happiness is
the end goal but in doing so we make
lots of people very unhappy and that's
because happiness is just a deflection
from the Baseline happiness sadness
grief anger jealousy regret remorse all
of these deflections play a role when I
failed to get the marks I needed to get
into med school first time around I
missed out my chemistry a grade by two
marks my coursework was moderated down
um and I missed out by place at
Liverpool
uh the head teacher rung and said Alex
would be a good student you know give
him a go nope
if I was walking around happy
that whole day it's smiling away
it'd be pretty weird I haven't been like
what is wrong with this guy he's just
lost his place in med school and also if
I was happy all the time I wouldn't do
anything no one does anything hard or
does anything without feeling
there is an urgency to do so there's an
intention to do so if I was just happy
all the time nothing if the whole human
race was happy all the time nothing
would get done
there would be no
there'd be no reason like imperative
Initiative for us to do anything that's
happy to find by like uh hedonistically
Happy rather than you demonically happy
or like yeah I think what happened
but I see I think the problem is it's
tarnished because we use as that I think
what people mean is peace I think it's
balance equilibrium right like human
dynamics in the body like
being in a state of of Peace as I think
the is the is the goal this kind of
hedonistic I agree with the absolute
idea of happiness I mean you know
chasing this feeling of like warm fuzzy
feeling all the time it just leaves you
to misery and also people then go well
if I'm not happy all the time there's
something wrong with me and that creates
discomfort and discontent and the
opposite of Peace when someone dies in
your family you should feel sad and
grief when something bad happens you
should feel frustration when you want to
achieve something and it feels far away
you want to feel determination and all
that kind of stuff and I think the real
goal is just finding that equilibrium
between everything I think no one should
live in anxiety all the time no one
should feel sad all the time I just feel
happy all the time you know we we've got
to find that balance between everything
and you'll find actually when you stop
chasing happiness as defined by the
hedonistic view of Happiness you'll
actually find that you're much more
content in life you know it's kind of
like a relationship if you're looking
for a relationship that's full of
Thrills and highs and craziness all the
time this kind of dopamine Rush of like
love all the time you know the Newton's
third law tells us every every
um every action has an equal and
opposite reaction of energy so a lot of
the kind of Love Drunk relationships
also have huge lows and huge arguments
and fallouts and so on really you want a
relationship with someone where you're
content you're at peace you balance each
other out and that generally you move
through life in a synergistic way that's
actually what most people want again in
love oh you should be looking for
someone that you know you can't stop
thinking about that sounds pretty bad
doesn't it to me that doesn't sound like
a good relationship but it's what we're
sold so I think redefining our view of
Happiness looking at it as like I want
to feel that in each day I generally
have a state of purpose there's a reason
to be that I get joy out of my day that
I'm able to deal with life's challenges
that I can create connection with people
that I spend a reasonable amount of time
doing things I enjoy I think that to me
sounds like a good life and just again
if in doubt ask yourself what does a
good life look like to me what does it
mean to have a good life well you know
when's the last time you sat down and
thought is this life that I have the
life that I want
and if it isn't what am I doing each day
to work towards the life I do want
if you're just moving constantly and
doing things because people expect you
you do and it's not essential and you
agree to stuff and don't have boundaries
before you'll know before you know it
you'll end up wherever the river's
taking you you know the river will take
you in the way in the direction that
it's flowing and if you allow yourself
to succumb to that you will just follow
the direction of that River you've got
to kind of I think you've got to
sometimes in life just stop you've got
to step out you've got to paddle towards
the shore get out of the river take a
moment to have a look at the direction
it's it's heading in and then decide if
that's what what you want discomfort
tells you something if you're feeling
discomfort in your life
signal it's like pain we learn about it
don't we the pain is telling you
something it's just a message it's just
telling you that there's something
happening you've got to make a decision
if you're going to take your hand out
the fire and all this your decision but
if you just don't look at your hand
that's burning you're not going to know
what's happening are you just gonna get
it carry on his way it's like oh well
should we like get rid of pain no we
need pain because you need pain to know
otherwise you you don't know when you're
standing leaning on on the stove you
know absolutely
Alex I think it's a great place to end
this thank you so much this has been
wonderful um any parting pieces of
advice wisdom for anyone who's listening
to this who's gotten 200 hours into this
conversation and is resonating with what
you say right it's the very final words
of wisdom this is a deep dive I think
for anyone that's struggling just please
know this too shall pass I think it's
one of the most powerful things that
I've ever read you know and if you're
facing a challenge then you know you can
overcome anything in life
with the right people around you if
you're struggling ask for help there is
no share in that see it as a sign of
strength and just never give up I mean
chase your dreams fear less
spend more time caring about what you
think rather rather than the opinions of
of others and I think you'll probably
end up somewhere near happiness as we
call it thank you for having me I really
appreciate it so much all right so
that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye